the year was 1997 when a climbing party
of five countries embarked on their
ascent of mount europe
their mission was to conquer this summit
in luxembourg in hindsight it was an
adventure to remember
some countries were faster slovenia
hungary poland czech republic
estonia i think as well
but the others i think the status of
those countries was stimulus for the
others to proceed faster
for example cyprus who caught up as the
summit loomed on the horizon the first
task for the brave six was to meet the
economic and political conditions to
exceed to the dizzy heights of eu
membership
they needed a solid base camp with
stable democracy and respect for the
rule of law their guide gunter hoyten
who was european commissioner for
enlargement at the time knew it was an
ambitious climb
and he had to convince the long-term
summit dwellers above all france
the point was not that they rejected the
idea of new members or that they wanted
to deny particular countries access to
the eu
the concern of the french was rather
that eu enlargement would change the
balance of power within the european
union in favor of germany and to their
own disadvantage
but the ongoing conflict in former
yugoslavia changed the mission's scope
and speed eastern enlargement suddenly
meant bringing in 10 countries as
quickly as possible sherpa gunther for
hoygen was a champion of what became
known as the big bang approach
the war in kosovo in 1999 made it clear
to everyone that war had not been
entirely banned from europe
in fact we understood that european
unity was the only reliable tool to
bring peace to europe for good
the new map of the eu would now look
like this
10 countries were now facing one last
steep climb at the copenhagen conference
at that point the summit appeared to be
very far away in fact i felt a bit like
we had to climb the north face of the
iger in the swiss alps but in the end we
made it it was a miracle
at the foot of the acropolis in athens
the eu's new and old leaders put down
their names in the summit book together
they had overcome the cold war division
of europe for good on may the 1st 2004
it was time to celebrate
but not all of the new members found it
easy going in their new environment the
financial crisis in europe posed
stunning challenges for many and even
former high achievers such as slovenia
were left struggling so i think we still
have to
think how to
fully implement
the principles
of rule of law of social market economy
also respect for human dignity i think
that we are still a country a former
communist country in the transition
where the 10 countries rushed into
getting to their destination
i do ask myself today whether we should
have done more to prepare the new
members for the fight against corruption
and to help them set up a more stable
justice system
but i have to say that the main problem
in these countries is not the absence of
strong institutions and legal agreements
it's rather the people themselves and
their political culture
that was particularly true for the next
countries to reach the summit
romania and bulgaria joined in 2007
croatia followed in 2013
you